Different people handle loss differently.
There are sore losers.
There are angry losers.
There are depressive losers.
There are narcissists who tend to go more
in the direction of I didn't want to win anyway.
There's a really broad range of reaction to
loss and it often changes over time.
We're seeing something really interesting
on Fox News, which is that suddenly they are
all about their feelings and the feelings
of conservatives and the feelings of Trump.
That's how everybody feels about the election
numbers, how everybody feels about the election
results, how some of their feelings are now
hurt by what has taken place.
And you've got to see some of these examples.
Here is one from Fox and Friends yesterday
morning where Ainsley Earhardt, one of the
hosts, says, you know, staunch conservatives,
they feel defeated.
They has a sad for lack of a better term.
Take a listen to what I think people who are
staunch conservatives in our country just
feel so, just so defeated because of this
election.
They do feel like it was rigged.
And then to see what's happening in Georgia
that the Democrats could have the House Democrats
could have the Senate and the presidency.
And that's that's the danger.
Did you hear that?
It's disheartening for staunch conservatives
that they lost.
Where was this understanding back in 2008?
Where was this understanding back in 2012?
I don't recall it from these same people.
Now, part of the irony of all this is that
the right has this idea of the facts don't
care about your feelings.
That's a meme that they love pushing on to
the left.
And now they all need time.
And we need to be careful with their feelings
because they are fragile and and and disheartened
by what they are seeing.
Here's another while, by the way, advocating
for the essentially for the setting aside
of the actual results because they just feel
bad about it.
Here's another one from yesterday on FOX.
This is Senator Ron Johnson who says we can't
just ignore the concerns and suspicions from
right wingers, I guess because there are concerns
and suspicions what we hold up Joe Biden's
inauguration.
Check this out.
Absent proof, absent evidence, Republican
Senator Ron Johnson says we can't just dismiss
the concerns of people here as well.
From my standpoint, we simply cannot dismiss
the concerns of tens of millions of Americans
that have have suspicions.
Wow.
We've got to be careful, guys.
The suspicions and concerns of these Americans
who have fallen for Donald Trump's bogus claims
about voter fraud.
They need to be babied because they feel bad.
And they want to put aside the results of
the election, it's just absolutely wacky.
And here's the cherry on top in this last
clip.
This is from the same episode of Fox and Friends
that we looked at in the first clip.
Fox reporter Griff Jenkins is in Dalton, Georgia.
That's the location of last night's Trump
rally.
And there's apparently a fan of Fox anchor
Ainsley Earhardt at the rally.
And the fan rushes over and every detail of
this exchange is bonkers.
Now, of course, neither the reporter nor the
Trump ist are wearing masks.
The guy actually has a shirt on that says
the only thing worse than covid-19 would be
Biden, 20, and he's hugging Griff Jenkins.
And you could actually hear Steve Doocy in
the Fox studio.
He sounds uncomfortable about what's going
on.
This is just out of this world.
I was going to say, go give Terry from Detroit,
our fan a big hug.
But we can't do that, right, Terry?
You can take him.
You can't consent to say two seconds on my
microphone.
What do you want to say to.
We love you, Ainslee.
Oh, Terry.
I love you.
Terry, I want to talk to you.
Came from Detroit.
Bless America.
God bless the president.
He loves you, too.
And she can't believe you came from Detroit.
Why do you come from Detroit?
Because I love the president.
We want to back him 100 percent.
All right.
Thank you, Jerry.
Look at that T-shirt.
What does this guy know, Terry?
What's your T-shirt say?
The only thing worse than covid-19 would be
Biden.
Twenty seven.
And that's the truth.
Thank you so much, Scott.
True.
God bless you, Terry.
Thank you, Griff.
We love.
All right.
Very nice to see.
Back to you.
All right.
Let's bring it.
They're doing this stuff with smiles on their
faces, if you can imagine that it is another
country out there.
Holy covid, my friends, is my only reaction.
What are these people going to do when when
former vice president and now President elect
Joe Biden is sworn in?
There are some who say it's going to be violence.
Others say it will be dejection and evaporation
into the ether.
I don't know the answer, but it's certainly
scary.